bonsoir à tous trois invités ce soir
trois invités dans proche parfois qui
ont fait leurs preuves lors des
élections législatives trois élus
effectivement d'abord est bien celui
qu'on appelle le tombeur de claude
guéant thierry solère bonsoir sont
affairés peut-être l'autre qualificatifs
qu'on vous prête le missile sol-air
c'est vous qui m'avez souffle et
justement cette émission au contraire
que les crises arabes
voilà ensuite le socialiste olivier
faure sera avec nous très proche de
françois hollande est de jean marc
ayrault
enfin le vert sergio coronado qui a
séduit les français d'amérique latine sa
terre d'origine voici donc nos trois
invités que nous recevons donc avec
samir tounsi de l' agence france-presse
bonsoir samir vous semez perrine
tarneaud de public sénat et avec vos
interventions et vos questions par le
biais de l'application tivi tchèque de
notre partenaire orange est donc d'abord
le député thierry solère bonsoir à
nouveau alors tombeur de l'ancien homme
fort de la sarkozie est ce que c'est un
titre de gloire pour vous non pas du
tout moi je crois que les habitants de
boulogne ont choisi leurs députés et que
on est élu un député on n'est pas nommé
merci pour ça que ça veut dire
d'accord mais je parlais de vous pas
moins des électeurs l'a vaincu alors
vous vous pensiez que le combat était
accessible dès le départ
moi c'était le calcul que j'avais fait
le raisonnement que j'avais fait et si
je suis content c'est que les boulonnais
ont compris le sens de ma candidature
et encore une fois je crois que les
électeurs ne sont pas des machines à
voter pour des formations politiques
c'est pas les partis qui font gagner les
candidats c'est les candidats qui
amènent des victoires à leurs formations
post-bac or même si l'image de votre
parti vous l'avez utilise on y reviendra
un peu plus tard perrine alors sur votre
analyse de l'échec de claude guéant à
boulogne comme droit à trois raisons la
première c'est qu'il a été parachuté je
crois qu'ils sont vraiment les
parachutages des pratiques qui ne
fonctionne plus on l'a vu la boule à mon
avis la rochelle on a vu dans les vosges
c'est les pratiques d'un autre âge
la deuxième raison c'est alors nice
boulogne billancourt eux c'est pas tout
à fait pareil mais il ya une dimension
commune bien sûr
deuxième raison c'est le positionnement
politique
vous dire que vous avez été aussi élu
avec des voix de la gauche non mais d'un
territoire
au premier tour les habitants c'est
toujours été comme ça on fait tous comme
ça en tant qu'électeur ont choisi leur
second tour on élimine bien sûr et donc
après il n'ya pas les bonnes voies et
des mauvais voire voyez des boulonnais
qui ont voté pour moi au premier tour il
ya des boulonnais qui ont voté pour moi
au second tour et là qu'elle est votée
guéant qui avait au 1er tour complété
pour moi derrière il ya sûrement des
gens qui ont été offensés le
positionnement politique de claude
guéant qui a incarné peut-être trop
souvent des clins d'oeil au front
national et nancy dans la nuit dans la
ville qui est la mienne à boulogne
billancourt
on l une droite qui droite républicaine
qui est tourné surtout sur les
problématiques économiques
et puis l'a3 est aussi c'est une ville
de centre-droit c était jean pierre
fourcade pendant des années quand on a
été à lemaire moi même je suis issu de
l'udf on a adhéré tous à l'ump qui a été
le règlement du rpr et l'udf et puis
après une troisième raison très local
qui est qu'ils aient le soutien du maire
de la ville et que le maire de la ville
il est assez récuser parce qu'il a
beaucoup d'opérations immobilières
c'était ça aux gens c'est à dire très
spécifique l'absence d'un vrai qu'on
prend alors un double insu immobilière
dans les hauts-de-seine le maire de
boudin billon conseiller en disant qu'il
allait d densifier la ville pour
s'asseoir agréable cadre de vie il veut
faire des tours de bureaux de 120 m de
haut par tour et notamment sur l'île
seguin
voyez donc il ya son soutien à peser
pour que bien voilà pour les régions
locales soit verdi
donc vous êtes vous avez été exclue
l'ump un moment donc aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes un aussi le falorni
l'ump la suite logique de cette
dynamique des parachutages que les
partis politiques devraient arrêter
c'est que quand on parachute quelqu'un
on exclut le candidat local moi je suis
ump toujours j'ai été pendant neuf ans
le patron de l'ump à boulogne il était
secrétaire national de l'ump claude
guirande demandé mon exclusion
c'était une candidat et j'ai été exclu
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un recours de
cette exclusion donc lors qu'on n'a pas
été jugé en tout cas j'ai vu christian
jacob
dès hier à l'assemblée nationale le
président actuel du groupe ump qui m'a
demandé à moi je lui ai dit oui que
j'intègre ce groupe ump donc j'ai
intégré le groupe humble engagé à les
marques de réintégration d'euros près
des ténors de l'ump comme vous promener
c'est déjà à l'assemblée nationale une
poignée de mains de xavier bertrand par
ci un échange avec eux christian jacob
non mais vous savez moi je suis ump
toujours les partis politiques c'est à
cause des coups de tampon sur des
commission d'investiture c'est avant
tout des idées voilà l'ump j'y suis
depuis la création depuis 9 ans j'ai été
élu j'ai bien compris que l'appareil
politique avait souhaité que ce soit aux
clients qu'ils soient élus là les
habitants de la ville ont tranché j'ai
été élu député
je suis ump de toujours et bien
évidemment j'intègre le groupe olympe et
rassemblez vous avez serré la main et
xavier bertrand vous avez parlé avec
christian jacob pour qui vous allez
voter demain à la présidence j'ai monté
ma d'abord j'ai appris simplement
aujourd'hui que xavier bertrand était
candidat à la présidence du groupe et il
ne m'échappe pas qu'il va y avoir à
l'automne au sein de l'ump un choix
opérés mais avant que ce soit le choix
la nomme ça avec le choix sur des idées
moi j'attends ça vous avez perdu près
des mureaux la faire avant l'automne
demain je pense qu'elle christian jacob
a été un bon président groupe est
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'on a perdu les
élections
on doit pas faire la bataille du mois de
novembre à l'assemblée nationale
christian jacob et le président du
groupe sûrs et donné il a parlé mais moi
je le vois très près c'est donc un
proche de jean françois copé donc vous
cautionnez la stratégie la stratégie du
ni ni qui a été celle de votre parti
entre les deux tours d'élections
législatives avaient été suspendus dans
goût et bien qu'on m'a pas demandé
l'avis sur le ni ni
moi je crois que ça sera ça le vrai
débat notamment on a été emmené dans un
pays où le front national a fait 18 %
des voix à l'élection présidentielle
c'est considérable
il ya deux solutions soit on veut
comme ça s'est passé en italie avec
gianfranco fini à l'époque qui a permis
en rompant avec la tradition fasciste de
l'extrême droite italienne de faire
l'alliance avec le parti de droite
républicaine italienne ou soit on
considère qu'on ne peut pas le faire
pour plein de raisons
moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire
cette alliance là parce que ce serait
renier les valeurs de la droite
républicaine c'est j'entends souvent ici
comme ailleurs des débats qu'ils disent
mais pourquoi
à droite on n'a pas le droit de faire
des alliances avec le front national
alors que la gauche fait des alliances
avec l'extrême gauche parce que c'était
la même chose parce qu'il ya eu la
guerre
acheté il a eu la collaboration parce
qu'élu l'extermination de beaucoup de
gens et que l'extrême gauche en france
elle était dans la résistance et que
l'extrême droite française parce que
vous ne l'était à l'époque du national
tenu ce discours prônant la vivarié que
nous entendons depuis longtemps par les
insignes m'écouter et j'en suis ravi
donc on ne peut pas renvoyer dos-à-dos
l'extrême gauche de front de gauche
jean-luc mélenchon et rip l'extrême
droite le front national marine le pen
non mais je pense que les idées de
l'extrême gauche sont absolument
adhérente d'un coeur des méchantes mais
réalisé d'ailleurs moi mais je pense que
à droite la droite l'extrême droite est
forte dans notre pays quand la droite
républicaine n'affirme pas les valeurs
qui sont les siennes et si la stratégie
c'est de faire des clins d'oeil aux
électeurs du front national
en reprenant une partie et thématiques
du front national pour que les électeurs
du fn denver nous ça ne fonctionne pas
voilà les électeurs du fn moi j'en ai
rencontré dans ma circonscription 5%
simplement que deux minutes de tamisage
connais le ni ni
c'est clair je considère que les
électeurs du fn que moi j'ai rencontré
je n'ai pas vu d'idéologues de la
hiérarchie des civilisations j'ai vu des
gens qui étaient exaspérés par ce qu'ils
étaient au chômage depuis longtemps
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gâchis parce
qu'ils considèrent que les pouvoirs
publics ne font pas leur travail
je n'ai pas vu des gens et non à droite
dans la droite républicaine si on veut
reconquérir les français il va faire
l'art clairement affirmer les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres et palais flirter
avec des idéologies qui ne sont pas
celles de la droite républicaine
justement dans la reconstruction de
l'ump vous condamner la stratégie d'une
limite donc vous compte
vous condamnez la stratégie de jean
françois copé pendant toute cette
campagne des législatives mais attendez
moi je veux pas être un pas que j'arrive
aujourd'hui à 40 ans l'assemblée
nationale est un grand donneur de leçon
je me condat ne rien
moi vous me posez une question forcément
pas de choisir aujourd'hui désorientés
c'est bien c'est l'orientation
automatique alors à lille tient à
l'automne au mois de novembre et avant
de choisir une personne il va falloir
avoir ce débat là ces débats là c'est
pas demain au groupe
on va la voir demain on les lit le
président notre groupe celui qui va
porter l'organisation de titres à des
travaux de l'ump au parlement moi je
soutiens
christian jacob parce que christian
jacob voilà derrière voilà la position
qui est la mienne je pense que c'est une
erreur de rentrée nous danser on retient
et c'est vrai que les voix de l'ump vous
êtes peut-être la première à le dire qu'
on ne peut pas renvoyer dos-à-dos
l'extrême gauche et extrême droite en
raison de ce qui s'est passé durant la
guerre puis peut-être de l'intervention
des communistes alors dans leur
existence est ce que vous citiez oui je
pense qu'il ya cette dimension là il ya
cette dimension là bien sûr maintenant
sur la et moi les électeurs que je
rencontre aujourd'hui ils me disent quoi
sur le terrain ils me disent si les gens
votent front national c'est parce que
vous faites pas votre travail donc si
vous voulez gagner les élections c'est
pas une année on ira jamais d'addition
des élections des électeurs entre le
froid qu'on a les lieux pérennes bernard
debré a dit aujourd'hui que le
sarkozysme est mort est-ce que vous
aussi vous réclamer un droit
d'inventaire
non moi je considère que pris dans la
république nicolas sarkozy a été un très
bon président le regret qui est le mien
c'est que la campagne électorale
nous avons vécu présidentielle n'est pas
permis de suffisamment mettre en valeur
le travail qui avait été fait pour
réformer le pays s'ils le trouvent c'est
le président de la république qui depuis
30 ans a fait le plus pour réformer
notre pays et on a passé la campagne à
courir derrière en s'excusant derrière
différents sujets qui ne sont pas les
nôtres à faire des erreurs
symbolique sinon beaucoup heurté parking
nos électeurs des clins d'oeil au front
national
un jour on y revient et c'est souvent ça
je serai à votre combat après ce non je
veux pas où c'est je ne veux pas qu'il
est moi je ne dis pas que le front
national est un parti nationaliste et
socialiste
voilà je vous dis c'est un parti
républicain qui s'inscrit dans la
république mais qui porte une idéologie
en tout cas pour une partie de ses
membres qui n'est pas celle de la
république avait justement on parlait de
poignées de main à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez croisé gilbert collard et
marion maréchal-le pen les deux
électeurs du les deux vérités du front
national je vais je savais quand vous
allez croiser c'est très symbolique mais
seul compte dans le petit monde de
l'assemblée nationale vous allez leur
serrer la main à pas bien sûr ce sont
des élus de la nation
d'ailleurs il ya des députés qui
seraient moins députés que d'autres moi
je respecte le choix des français par
les joueurs
enfin je vais en parler avec eux des
textes de loi il a renvoyé vente une
stratégie commune face à face à la face
à la majorité laisse et le lieu des
débats
donc évidemment vous parler à tous les
parlementaires qui représentent les
français on devrait pas parler à une
partie des français n'ont bien sûr pas
d'accord moi je vous dis je l'attendais
pour qu'on soit bien précis moi je vous
dis que ma formation politique qui est
celle de la droite républicaine
elle n'arrivera pas à reconquérir les
français si elle ne se rend pas compte
qu'il faut que les français attendent de
nous une culture du résultat je pense
qu'une chose je pense que le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
partout ça a été une erreur et notamment
dans là dans la police quand je vois les
effectifs mois de police qui ont baissé
dans ma ville on est passé de 85 à 55
je me dis si c'est partout pareil en
france vous avez beaucoup de français
qui ont eu pu avoir le sentiment d'être
abandonnés et voyez les électeurs du
front national
je pense à marseille où on annonce des
morts malheureusement par arme à feu
très très fréquemment si les effectifs
de police diminuent ils considèrent pour
les abandonne c'est ça qu'ils attendent
les français accor il avait promis aux
poses série no9 sur tvcheck exactement
notre application avec notre partenaire
orange une question de caroline est ce
que patrick devedjian est en ce moment
l'homme à abattre dans le 92 dans les
hauts-de-seine coûté une des parts voir
le département des hauts de seine
j'aimerais bien que ça cesse et je pense
que si cette question est posée c'est
notamment en relation avec le livre de
sa collaboratrice mary si guillon qui
est sorti qui s'appelle le monarque son
fils son fief
il décrit la vie politique dans ce
département est ce qu'il correspond à la
réalité
maintenant je n'ai pas le livre c'est
pas une progression non je commence à le
dire sont rejoints j'ai lu des taxes et
bien sûr j'ai lu des extraits je sais
que je pense qu'elle est mais je n'ai
pas lu et je vais le faire parce qu'il
faut savoir précisément de croire ou pas
on sait pas très habile le voyais quand
vous êtes dans une collectivité locale
de faire un livre brûlot où on envoie
les gens doit dans ce département ça a
été celui du chef de l'état nicolas
sarkozy est par nature derrière il ya eu
beaucoup d'excès de part et d'autre le
ranger tous les acteurs pardon
monarchique non pas du président de la
république à la part des acteurs locaux
et qui le maniait la reconsidérer oui
mais patrick devedjan plus que d'autres
nous tous moi même peut-être on a tous
certains ont peut-être oublié
il ya un moment donné il fallait
peut-être fehrer ça nous a donné plus de
devoirs que de droits d'être issu du
département nicolas sarkozy va t il vous
êtes un proche de jean sarkozy et que
vous aviez soutenu lors de la sphère de
l'ehpad a ce qu'il vous a félicité
dimanche soir ça nous avait battus
claude brillante
alors je suis un proche de sarkozy je le
revendique je pense d'ailleurs que c'est
un garçon de grands alors je pense que
oui d'abord j'ai horreur de la chasse à
l'homme est donc d'être le fils d'un
président de la république je pense que
c'est difficile d'ailleurs thomas landes
depuis une dizaine de jours doit rendre
compte lui-même mais je n'ai pas soutenu
jean sarkozy dans les félicite et lui
est dure pour vous de tenir durant cette
campagne dure face à claude coeur mais
vous savez moi j'ai un travail dans la
vie et j'essaie de défendre des
convictions et pas de lire après des
palabres hauteur et lui parce que je ne
vis pas de demande maintenant je vais
vous dire parlementaire donc évidemment
je vais mettre en conformité avec tout
ça mais vous savez quand vous la
question si c'est votre ma réponse faire
vous allez on peut voir un métier puis
quand même affronté mais c'est beaucoup
plus facile quand on est vendu de
rudesse en forme de soit entendu par le
système je n'ai jamais les villes et nos
relations politiques
vous affectez mois peut-être que
certains mais vous avez bon je dois
d'abord je salue claude guéant d'une
manière tout à fait républicaine dans
cette campagne je dois vous dire que la
campagne s'est globalement bien passée
je n'ai rien à reprocher
laissez vous oubliez un peu alors
précipité la retraite de claude guéant
non mais je me positionne pas comme ça
on est en démocratie
d'accord je me présente devant les
boulonnais ils ont été pour moi j'en
suis ravi merci thierry solère on a
compris un peu déjà qu'elle était un
petit peu votre marche de conduite pour
les cinq années qui viennent à
l'assemblée nationale et puis à l'ump
également olivier faur nouveau député
socialiste de seine et marne va vous
succéder il a fait non pleine campagne
de porte à porte mais at on lu dans les
journaux de banquette à banquette c'est
à dire dans le rer ce très proche du
président de la république et du premier
ministre découvre donc ces jours-ci
l'assemblée côté travées à l'heure où le
retour à la réalité salaire peut être
brutal pour les français élisent à
berthelot mais rigueur le mot est lâché
dès le lendemain des législatives le
gouvernement prépare à l'effort un
effort qui se conjuguera en deux étapes
d'abord définir le budget 2012
le dérapage du déficit public contraint
le gouvernement à trouver 10 milliards
d'euros
un véritable tour de vis va s'opérer le
gouvernement pourrait tailler dans le
budget de l'assurance maladie et réduire
les prestations sociales ensuite prévoir
le budget 2013
l'audit de la cour des comptes publiés
début juillet devrait confirmer les
efforts à faire en matière de réduction
des dépenses de l'état
si le gouvernement veut tenir ses
engagements une augmentation des impôts
s'avérera nécessaire dans la réalité on
va augmenter une partie impôts en partie
en français on est sur les rangs de la
fois plus juste mais globalement
l'addition sera là et deuxième aspect il
y aura quand même à l'évidence une
réduction de la part des dépenses lui
dans le pipe c'est ce qui était proposé
un programme de deux points en cinq ans
à part manuel valls le gouvernement
rechigne à parler ouvertement de rigueur
pierre moscovici réfute toute politique
d'austérité préférant le terme d'efforts
cher à françois hollande pendant la
campagne présidentielle
voilà qui est fort nous a rejoint
bonsoir soit on va parler tout de suite
de la rigueur même si le mot a été
prononcé par le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls parce qu'on peut dire que
non pas pour passer de la nuit à la
lumière là c'est une expression qui
rappelle 3980 mais de l'ombre à la
lumière des coulisses à la lumière
aujourd'hui en devenant député jeunesse
façon oui parce que effectivement
pendant longtemps j'ai travaillé avec la
république et puis avec premier ministre
quand il n'était pas encore dans ces
fonctions là et aujourd'hui c'est un
immense honneur de pouvoir à servir mon
pays d'une autre façon en étant
effectivement des lumas nation famille
prétendent être autre chose qu'un député
godillot quand vous avez été aussi
proche collaborateur de françois
hollande pendant sept ans dans sept ans
et de jean marc ayrault à l'assemblée
nationale peut-on être un député
indépendant
je crois qu'il me connaît et ça que je
ne serai pas un beau dire mais parce
qu'il ya des liens personnels quai
quasiment amicaux qui nous unissent à
l'actuel chef de l'état et au projet
parce que pour rendre service à un
président un premier ministre
il ne faut pas leur dire ce qu'ils
veulent entendre mais ce qui peut leur
rendre sa liste vraiment et donc leur
dire ce que pense le pays réel les
emmener là aussi où on pense que la
voyait juste l'effet pervers du
entourage alors je sais que l'entourage
peuvent être effectivement gré des taux
d' ivoire pour celui qui ne prennent pas
garde
et moi j'ai toujours dit que je serai de
ceux qui avec françois hollande ou jean
marc ayrault
il ré le jour où ça n'ira pas leur dire
et ne pas me retrancher derrière une
attitude de courtisans que je n'ai
jamais été que je ne conduis pas de
venir vous avez évidemment laisser votre
poste de conseiller de jean marc ayrault
que vous étiez jusqu'à une date récente
date très récente fête dimanche soir
vous ne dites plus je me suis plu arrive
la bataille pour le perchoir qui se
dessine est ce que vous savez déjà vous
pour qui vous avez envie de voter pour
la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
mais puisqu'on parlait de députés
godillots justement là on est dans une
phase un choix il ya trois candidats
pour l'instant je n'ai entendu aucun des
trois mois ce que je souhaite c'est un
président qui une présidente qui exprime
une vision différente du parlement qui
explique ce que peut être le
renouvellement la vie parlementaire la
façon dont on peut s'articuler le
travail de l'exécutif avec le législatif
et donc lorsque j'ai entendu ces
trois-là dire ce qui les différencie
à ce moment là je ferai mon choix même
pour l'instant c'est trop tôt car
jean-louis alors les deux les noms on le
rappelle donc jean claude bartolone jean
glavany et il habite bigot et une
ambiguïté tout cet après midi tout ce
mardi après-midi sion marylise lebranchu
faisait des nouvelles elle reste au
gouvernement elle abandonne son poste au
ministre pour se présenter au perchoir
je crois que là plusieurs reprises
exprimé son choix qui est celui de
rester utile au gouvernement est de
continuer à travailler sur des dossiers
qu'elle connaît bien pour les avoir déjà
assumé pendant quatre ans dans la phase
d'opposition et visiblement elle subi
beaucoup de pression pour être
candidates on cherche une femme avant
tout est ce qu elisabeth guigou ne fait
pas la faire non mais je crois pas qu'on
cherche une femme avant tout françois
hollande a dit aussi pendant toute la
campagne
bien qu'il fasse bien qu'il ya une femme
c'est vrai que si on peut avoir une
femme de l'assemblée ça semble difficile
aujourd'hui de revenir en arrière et de
mettre un homme à la tête de l'assemblée
nationale si sa patronne et puis à jean
glavany je peux assurer qu'il entende
comme ça non je crois qu'il faut
effectivement si c'est possible de
trouver un candidat ou une candidate
le consensus si c'est pas possible il
faut qu'il ya un vote c'est la
démocratie c'est bien olivier favier de
très près avec martine aubry vous avez
le don d'ubiquité au parti socialiste
non mais souvent on dit que je suis le
fils unique de martine aubry françois
hollande est c'est vrai le seul à avoir
travaillé avec l'un et l'autre ont très
bien et comment est ce que vous comparer
leurs deux personnalités est-ce qu'ils
sont différents stands ont véritablement
où c'est mission impossible vous êtes le
seul à voir dir centre est ici la
jonction
j'aime les deux voilà je sais pour moi
c'est pas une difficulté c'est vrai
qu'ils ont des caractères très
différents
martin est peut-être plus fonceuse plus
frondeuse et françois peut être plus
consensuel mais le consensuel mais plus
en le rassemblement en plus je
je vais vous raconter une anecdote il ya
dix ans je me suis fait beaucoup anglais
par martine aubry parce que j'avais déjà
été interrogé sur la même question et
j'avais répondu face à l'iceberg
martine aubry prend enfin je vous
rappelle celle entre à l'étrave du
bateau et donc elles fondre devant el
prat des brises l'iceberg et françois
hollande le contourner tous deux
arrivent au bout et elle m'avait
vraiment quand même content que tu as
des choses pareilles et s'est maintenu
en tout les cas je maintiens que l'un et
l'autre savent tenir un cap et aller là
où ils veulent mais ils prennent les
meilleures différents du coup ça veut
dire que sa décision de quitter la
direction du parti socialiste est ferme
et définitive à je crois qu'elle a sa
décision ferme et définitive c'est pas
une femme qui change comme ça un avis
oui et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
françois hollande puisqu'il l'a voit
s'éloigner du parti socialiste dans tous
les cas de sa tête
non je crois pas que ce soit une bonne
nouvelle mais je trouve que ce qui était
très bien pendant cette campagne des
législatives est ce qu'on a servi à tous
nos candidats savoir un parti
socialiste- rassemblés pendant des
années les français en douter de nous
parce qu'ils me voyaient nous divise et
perpétuellement et donc ces images de
congrès en congrès de conclave en
conclave de complot en complot avait
fini par lasser et par donner le
sentiment que nous ne serions jamais
prêt à diriger ensemble ce qui rassure
les français c'est de nous voir réunis
rassembler on l'est c'est très bien et
donc voilà alors qu'ils ne reconnaîtront
pas non plus l'opinion
ça ne trompe pas l'opinion comme c'est
purement une façade mais je crois pas
que ça le soit franchement moi je vais
pas fâché martine aubry est quasiment
tous les jours au téléphone je vois jean
marc ayrault tous les jours on se parle
beaucoup mais de tous pour gérer
l'intégralité des affaires de ce pays
pour vérifier que les points de vue sont
bien semblable et ça se passe très bien
contrairement à peut-être ce que les un
autre avertissement rôle de médiateur
entre différentes personnalités pas
besoin de médiateur mais enfin tout cas
ce que je peux vous assurer c'est que
ils se parlent beaucoup
il se voit beaucoup et ça se passe très
bien
alors on vous suit est ce qu'il faut
laisser ségolène royal en dehors de ce
dispositif on a l'impression que le
parti socialiste semble en ce moment en
chercher à tout prix un poste
d'atterrissage pour ségolène royal est
ce qu'il faut là recasé à tout prix mais
il s'agit pas de passe quand on dit
recaser ça nous le sentiment qu'on a
besoin de lui retrouver quelque chose
pour faire plaisir c'est pas pour lui
faire plaisir c'est qu'on est relative
oui mais c'est pas pour lui faire
plaisir à ce qu'on souhaite nous c'est
qu'elle puisse continuer à prendre part
à la vie politique de manière active
parce qu'elle ait donc ne pas être en
dehors du dispositif à travers du
dispositif et continuer à servir notre
idée commune
c'est pas une façon de la haye a pas
d'idée de bons raté ça donne ça c'est
qu'elle est utile et j'ajoute que j'ai
été longtemps un camarade de jeu avec
les falorni et je m'aime je veux dire
une chose je comprenais qu'il puisse
être candidat au premier tour face à
ségolène royal
mais ce que je n'ai pas admis est ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est qu'il est se
soit maintenu au second tour contre
toutes les règles qui sont celles qui
sont les règles républicaines
il y avait une primaire qui était le
premier tour au second tour il fallait
qu'il se retire est en réalité celle qui
était la candidate légitime pour la
gauche au second tour c'était ségolène
royal il s'est pas retirée il est
maintenant élu c'est comme ça mais il
n'empêche que pour moi il ya une
injustice à réparer et il ya aussi un
besoin collectif c'est de continuer à
vivre avec l'une de ceux qui peuvent
permettre aux politiques de se rénover
olivier falorni à l'assemblée a signé
pour cinq ans de solitude vous allez
laissez le vous allez le laisser cinq
ans tout seul isolé alors que cet
après-midi en arrivant à l'assemblée il
a dit qu'il voulait siéger à gauche avec
vous mais c'est lui qui s'est isolé
personne ne nous a demandé d'être
candidat jusqu'au bout il sera réintégré
un jour au groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée combien durera la paix n'est
pas close hier sous le je crains que
la pénitence me soit long pour lui ça
peut être long cinq ans je pense que ça
peut être très long parce que c'est un
masque majoritaire c'est ça en plus
peut-être enfin par ailleurs le problème
c'est que il a enfreint une règle qui
est des règles de base pour nous si tout
le monde se met à considérer qu' il n'y
a pas de règles qu'on peut faire un peu
n'importe comment qu'on peut être élu au
premier tour sur une base au second tour
une autre et puis après revenir siéger
sur une troisième base
évidemment ça complique singulièrement
le jeu démocratique ce qui n'est pas
notre volonté est donc il ya une
virtuelle exemple alors on a parlé il ya
un instant d d'austérité olivier faur on
a l'impression qu'il ya un retour à la
réalité depuis lundi peut-être pas
encore pour vous vous étiez encore bien
sûr dans les bulles de champagne après
votre élection à on était déjà sans
champagne est ce que vous redoutez que
les mesures budgétaires et fiscales qui
seront immanquablement a lancé il faut
dès cette année trouver 10 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour respecter
le déficit premier à bruxelles ne
transforme cette victoire en gueule de
bois d'abord pour les électeurs de
gauche alors je crois que c'est la
première élection présidentielle qui
s'est joué sur un terrain de fond que
tel celui de scepticisme les français ne
croient plus aux grandes promesses et
grands engagements et ils ont choisi un
président la république qui leur a en
réalité assez peu promis qui a fixé une
seule priorité qui est celle de la
jeunesse et qui a tout de suite fixé le
cap ce qui était difficile pour la
gauche c'était de dire nous allons
réduire les déficits et nous avons un
objectif qui est très claire donc il a
peu promis il a peu détaillé non plus
sur les mesures
oui la fifa un cap qui a un cap clair
après il ya une question qui est celle
du rythme c'est vrai que la situation
financière budgétaire est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut pas précipiter
les choses et que ce qui nous est
demandé c'est non pas d'aller n'importe
comment et d'avoir dans trois ans hassam
étonnante de la rigueur comme celui
qu'on a connu en 83 ce qu'on demande
c'est d'agir avec calme et de prendre
les bonnes décisions pour arriver à bon
port louis dans cinq ans mais la rigueur
ça y est nous y sommes déjà est ce que
vous craignez un retour de bâton de
de l'électorat non ne s'agit pas s'il
s'agit de l'arrivée on parle simplement
de rigueur de gestion
oui il s'agit pas de dire que nous
sommes la hausse des réductions des
dépenses et sur les impôts sur les
impôts il s'agit pas augmenter les
impôts de tout le monde
il s'agit pas de revenir à la tva
sociale il s'agit de faire en sorte que
ceux qui sont les plus riches parmi les
français payent davantage aujourd'hui
que l'entreprise pèsent davantage
aujourd'hui le fira pas c'est à dire que
c'est pas il s'agit pas de viser ni les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires qui sont l épargne et qui au
contraire par exemple rentrée scolaire
vous bénéficiez alors de l'augmentation
de 25% famille allait rapidement vous
êtes élu de la seine-et-marne de cette
france périurbaines où le front national
fait de bons scores et également est ce
que comme on commence à l'entendre au ps
cette mandature c'est la dernière chance
pour un parti de gouvernement
traditionnels comme le ps avant la
percée définitive du front national qui
serait accueillir des électeurs qui
quitte définitivement ne croiront plus
ni à l'ump ni au ps
est ce qu'il ya un risque démocratique
qu'est ce que tu portes un je ne sais
pas ce que vous ferez les électrices et
les électeurs socialistes aujourd'hui si
demain nous devions échoué effectivement
il existe toujours un risque que la 26e
soit l'alternative la plus dure est donc
ce soit le front national moi j'ai parlé
avec beaucoup d'électeurs nationale
parce qu'aujourd'hui le fait nouveau
c'est que il ne s'en cache plus et donc
on a la possibilité de dialoguer de
manière assez franche qu'est ce que j'ai
compris de ce qu'il me disait c'était
que après j'ai pas cherché de la grotte
de seconde mais moi je rencontre des
gens tout le temps qu'ils sont des gens
qui se lèvent très tôt le matin qui
prennent leur voiture qui vont jusqu'à
la gare du rer qui trouve pas forcément
une place
j'ai fait campagne dans l'erreur qu'ils
trouvent pas façon une place au parking
qui se garent n'importe où qu'ils
partent prendre le rer qui prennent deux
heures de transport travail pendant huit
heures qui reviennent toujours de france
pour un nouveau regagner chez eux un pv
son pare brise qui sont garés n'importe
où il rentre à la maison et là ils sont
exténués mais ils vont se coucher
l'homme un rebelote et ces gens là ils
disent le problème pour nous c'est que
nous on fait cet effort là il a d'autres
qui le font pas et donc c'est tout le
thème de l'assistanat on peut le
comprendre parce qu'ils disent c'est
nous qui payons pour tout le monde alors
même que les autres ne paye plus mais ce
que j'aurais dit ne vous trompez pas de
colère le problème c'est pas celui que
vous prenez pour un assisté
notre problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il n'avait pas le retour sur
investissement services publics qui ont
disparu c'est les transports publics qui
sont défaillants c'est l'accès aux soins
qui est de plus en plus compliqué c'est
l'éducation qui n'est pas ce qu'elle
devrait être réparti entre les cinémas
dont nous sommes les centièmes en termes
de taux d'encadrement alors savoir une
démographie n'est plus galopante donc
voilà ce sont des choses comme ça qui
peuvent ramener nous avons créé vers nos
projets pour le futur pour le nouveau
gouvernement
une dernière question un peu plus légère
en 2007 après la campagne présidentielle
vous aviez publié une bd intitulée ségo
françois à papa et moi une bd qui vous
avez peut-être valu quelques inimitiés
je ne sais pas au ps vous racontiez la
campagne les coulisses
est ce que vous allez faire de même pour
la campagne de 2012 vous êtes
dessinateur de bd ainsi j'ai été
longtemps un cancre avant d'être un bon
élève et donc j'ai beaucoup dessiné au
fond d'une place cette fois-ci réalité
même si on me dira de l'époque m'a
rappelé pour me demander si je voulais
faire quelque chose peut-être se
rassembler peut-être sur la sans
désespérer bien prévient même question
que posait samir total à bout pour vous
aller serrer la main des deux députés
front national bien sûr bien sûr ça ne
pose aucun problème pour moi ils sont
élus du peuple
je le respecte en tant que tel ça veut
pas dire que nous soutiendrons amis
pendant la législature ça c'est autre
chose
très bien merci beaucoup au lift yeux
une idée fort merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
dernier invité nouveaux venus également
à l'assemblée nationale sergio coronado
élus verts de très loin venus de très
loin
je ne parle pas de la campagne
présidentielle qui l'a mené aux côtés
d'eva joly mais ce député des français
de l'étranger a été élu par les français
installés en amérique latine tam tran
huy pour
ce nouvel élu d'un groupe constitué donc
aujourd'hui par europe ecologie les
verts
ce dimanche 17 juin
elle fera une grande et très belle date
dans l'histoire des écologistes une
grande date free pour cause les
écologistes ont obtenu dimanche dernier
un groupe à l'assemblée nationale une
première depuis la naissance du parti et
une performance qu europe ecologie les
verts doit aussi aux socialistes
on voit que l'accord négocié qui avait
relativement été décriée par les
français ou au sein du ps entre europe
ecologie les verts et le ps entre cécile
duflot jean vincent placé et martine
aubry a permis aux verts d'assurer
l'essentiel être représentés à
l'assemblée nationale dans ces
conditions difficile pour les
écologistes de conserver une voix
indépendante
l'accord de mandature conclu avec le ps
fin 2011 comportait déjà quelques
entorses aux idées écologistes sur le
volet nucléaire
mais pour jean vincent placé pas
d'inquiétude sur l'avenir d'inféodation
ou de vassalisation nous sommes en
soutien fidèle loyal aux politiques
représentés le premier ministre donc la
feuille de route
après nous aurons entendre la voie
technologique malgré leurs dénégations
les verts vont devoir faire le dos rond
dans les prochains mois et apparaissent
pour l'instant pieds et poings liés au
puissant parti socialiste d'autant plus
que le ps a obtenu la majorité absolue
au palais-bourbon majorité absolue ça
veut dire que le ps peut se passer si je
me suis ici je puis dire on n'est pas
sous la menace de ses alliés europe
ecologie les verts et front de gauche
bref les écologistes ont pour l'instant
loin d'être indispensable mais le parti
socialiste ne sera peut-être pas
toujours aussi puissant et populaire
alors leur temps sera venu voilà sergio
coronado est avec nos bons soirs et le
vert donc à l'assemblée nationale est
toujours en plein décalage horaire
toujours on s'habitue en fait recyclés
début sans doute sans doute venu c'est
une circonscription qui compte 33 pays
qui va des mexique jusqu'à l'argentine
et qui comprend les caraïbes donc on a
fait hier où étiez-vous par exemple hier
matin enfin il ya eu dimanche soir
j'étais au mexique et hier matin j'étais
à madrid en escale et c'est comme ça que
j'ai appris par un coup de fil de
martine aubry mon élection à la
féliciter directement par martine aubry
alors ben c'est pas mal parce que
j'étais à la fois écologistes mais
soutenu par le parti socialiste donc on
que la gauche se réjouissent d'un élu
supplémentaire pour la majorité
parlementaire il ya rien de plus normal
bien sûr elle a passé beaucoup de coup
de fil dit quoi peut nous trois autour
notable quand on a un problème on veut
voir nos députés à la permanence vous si
un français lochois ya qu un problème où
vous allez prendre l'avion pour aller
voir comment vous allez exercer votre
mandat on parle d'abord il existe des
élus déjà pour les français de
l'étranger
si son roman terre nom est d'abord il ya
le conseil des français médias
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
moi j'avais bénéficié d'une très grande
chance l'ensemble des élus de gauche de
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
de ma circonscription ont soutenu ma
candidature ont fait campagne à mes
côtés j'avais d'ailleurs l'un d'entre
eux comme suppléant françois boucher du
mexique
donc ce sont des élites qui est kadri
déjà la circonscription
dans des régions déterminées et puis
ensuite moins j'aurai des délégués dans
chacun des pays et puis vous savez les
moyens internet aujourd'hui existent et
permettent en tout cas ont permis
pendant la campagne à celles et ceux qui
voulaient me contacter et de le faire
par skype par internet
voilà donc il aurait un contact quand
même physique avec vos électeurs va
manger plus souvent mois dans un pays
latino américains tout à fait moi j'ai
pris l'engagement de me déplacer
régulièrement et de tenter de couvrir
les pays de ma circonscription au moins
une fois par produire un mot sur votre
parcours personnel puisque vous êtes
menés au chili je suis né au chili j'ai
grandi en argentine selon son parti
après le coup d'état en fait du chili
je suis venu en france en 82 je suis
devenu français en 94 donc assez tard
dont je suis bi national comme la
majorité des français établis hors de
france en fait en tout cas ceux de ma
circonscription et puis ensuite j'ai
décroché une bourse de recherche et je
suis parti m'installer en colombie
pendant leur accord qu'est ce qui était
le plus difficile pour vous mener cette
campagne auprès des français de
l'étranger ou bien être aux côtés d'eva
joly pendant la présidentielle et de con
côté d'eva joly ça a été une expérience
tout à fait passionnante et intéressante
ça a été difficile comme campagne a été
violemment attaqué je le rappelle votre
première campagne présidentielle nous
avons notamment déjà travaillé auprès de
noël mamère que j'allais occupe
évidemment le peu près le même poste
chargé de la communication au père noël
mamère en 2001 avec un peu plus de
succès à peu plus de ce que c'est quoi
qu'il faut le nuancer ce succès là parce
que c'est un succès de premier tour et
qui n'a pas permis que la gauche
remporte l'élection parce que je m'y
perds pas été absent du soutien d'amis
d'épitaphe ils ont loupé rançon n'a pas
fait un très bon premier tour mais les
deux et demi pour cent quand même permis
à françois hollande de prévoir l a vu
que c'est pas mal
elle a beaucoup été attaqués avez vous
dit elle a beaucoup attaqué elle aussi
notamment ses partenaires et le progrès
le programme le projet présidentiel de
françois hollande
vous vous serez avait pété loyal je
pense qu'on peut être un député
solidaire d'une majorité parlementaire
et on peut être aussi un député engagé
sur ses propres convictions
ce n'est pas un secret que les
écologistes ne sont pas devenus
socialiste par la magie de l'élection
donc nous avons quelques divergences et
des nuances avec nos partenaires
socialistes
il ya eu un accord entre nos partis à
nador et bénéficie pour notre addiction
pas uniquement c'est un accord à la fois
programmatique et électorale et moi
j'entends que qui vont quand même
vis-à-vis du parti socialiste une
histoire de tenue par un accord c'est un
accord qui a été co élaborés construit
ensemble donc moi je souhaite que à la
fois les propositions de françois
hollande soit appliquée il a commencé à
le faire et que les engagements pris par
les socialistes et les écologistes dans
le cadre de l'accord commun va puisse
être menée à bien notamment sur la
question de la transition énergétique
est ce que vous allez voter tous les
textes de la majorité socialiste est ce
que vous vous réserver le droit de dire
non évidemment est ce que vous allez
lire au centre de cette note us est plus
violent du nouveau centre souhaite moi
je n'ai pas envie d'être l'équivalent du
nouveau centre non j'ai envie simplement
de faire exister le groupe écologiste
qui pour la première fois se constitua à
l'assemblée c'est pas écrit
moi j'ai pas envie d'être le poil à
gratter ou je ne sais quoi de cette
majorité parlementaire je crois qu'on a
la chance
historiquement d'appartenir au premier
groupe écolo donc on a une vraie
responsabilité
elle tient en deux piliers c'est
l'appartenance à une majorité
parlementaire et ce à des obligations de
solidarité et puis on est aussi le
premier groupe écolo donc on a une
obligation vis-à-vis de celles et ceux
qui nous ont fait confiance
exemple très concret sur le budget est
ce que vous vous serez tous les budgets
est-ce que l'obligation de solidarité de
solidarité que vous évoquez inclut le
vote des budgets
des gouvernements et aux joueurs par
mois mais ils sont frappés au coin de
l'austérité je crois personnellement que
votre contre le budget tu es contre le
budget ça ne veut pas dire s'abstenir ou
de ne pas prendre part au vote est un
acte politique majeur et qui est un acte
finalement un peu de ruptures
cela dit je voudrais rappeler quand même
que les socialistes n'ont pas besoin de
leurs alliés écologistes aujourd'hui
pour faire passer une mesure à la seule
excuse bénéficient d'une majorité
absolue
j'espère néanmoins malgré cette
situation rend libre non ça nous
n'aurons pas plus libre en tout cas ça
nous rend tout aussi responsables que
les socialistes je pense que quand on
bénéficie d'une majorité parlementaire
on a aussi l'obligation de faire vivre
l'ensemble de la gauche et l'ensemble de
la majorité parlementaire il y à des
communistes
il y à des radicaux il y a des
écologistes il y a des députés front de
gauche donc c'est aussi l'obligation de
celui qui est le mieux représenté à
l'assemblée que de faire vivre cette
majorité dans la cohérence et la
solidarité
bon ça veut dire que vous ferez contre
le budget de la défense mais que vous
attirez ou que vous saurez que vous
aurez tout et on verra sur les têtes
viendront débat vous savez il y a le
débat en commission il est ensuite le
débat en sciences venir avec les
amendements et puis moi je ne fais pas
de paris négatif sur ce qui va se passer
j'ai l'impression que françois hollande
et jean marc ayrault se débrouille
plutôt bien en ce début de quinquennat
nous irons à l'oeuvre être député à part
entière totalement pourtant quel est le
taux de participation dans votre
éminence circonscrire un taux de
participation faible mais classé 61e les
chiffres sur 73 mille inscrits il ya eu
un peu plus de six mille votants
deuxième tournoi je savais qu'il eut
avec trois minutes à faire
moi j'avais j'avais avec 3300 et voit
tout à fait vous savez que c'est une
circonscription qui comporte trois pays
où le vote internet a été un fiasco
véritablement pour le vote par
correspondance n'a pas fonctionné donc
badjoko promoteur va vraiment se poser
la question de la légitimité
démocratique de cet effet la légitimité
c'est l'élection qui la donne et puis
ensuite c'est le travail accompli par le
parlementaire une fois élu avez vous eu
le jeu qu'on se dit qu'il devrait être
prompt à condamner
un système qui semble je ne suis pas
prompts à condamner je suis là pour
l'améliorer pour permettre que ces
français là qui sont établies en dehors
de france puisse exercer pleinement leur
citoyenneté ça me paraît crucial ça me
paraît important donc une des
responsabilités que nous aurons les
députés élus par les français de
l'étranger c'est de faire en sorte que
la prochaine fois c'est qu'il ya déjà
douze sénateurs qui représente depuis
longtemps elle pensait établi à les
trouver ce qu'on avait besoin de 11
députés en plus pour représenter les
français de l'étranger
c'est une mesure qui a été voté par le
gouvernement de france hajj est vous
vous être présenté par des sénateurs et
des députés
je vois pas pourquoi un français établis
hors de france aurait deux mois de
pouvoir - deux représentations - de
représentativité pardon et une
citoyenneté moindre hoquet la vôtre il
est français comme vous et moi
donc on a établi un équilibre on a mis
fin à une sorte de discrimination dont
ils bénéficient d'une représentation
théo sénat et à l'assemblée ça me paraît
une bonne chose alors sur le sommet de
rio peut-être en dire un mot quand même
quel est l'intérêt aujourd'hui de ce
genre de gros raouts mondiale alors
qu'elle à chaque fois l'impression que
sa seule soit par un échec soit par des
avancées qui sont très minimes
là on parle déjà des échecs c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une configuration qui est
assez plombé par la crise économique
donc la transition écologique nécessite
de mobiliser des moyens et aujourd'hui
on a du mal à trouver des financements
vote les pays émergents refusent la
croissance verte proposée par l'onu
aujourd'hui les modèles de croissance
proposée je pense qu'il ya une
interrogation sur ce qu'est le
développement et la croissance et c'est
pas une mauvaise chose
moi je le regrette évidemment que des
pays comme les etats unis
l'angleterre soit absent de ce sommet
mais au moins je crois qu'il est
nécessaire et c'est une des propositions
qui va discuter d'élaborer une nouvelle
gouvernance et notamment dans le domaine
de l'environnement donc la mise en place
d'une organisation aux pouvoirs élargis
une organisation de l'environnement me
paraît nécessaire je crois qu'il est
jusque là mondiale tout à fait est plus
qu urgent que ces questions là soit
affronter de manière coordonnée et que
ça mobilise toutes les énergies
évidemment qu'on peut regretter le peu
d'enthousiasmé des pays émergents mais
le nord a une responsabilité c'est à
dire que nous avons bâti notre
croissance sur un modèle d'exploitation
des ressources y manière totalement
irresponsable et aujourd'hui on n'est
pas habilité à faire la leçon
donc il faut dialoguer il faut faire des
transferts de technologie et je pense
qu'il faut donner les moyens politiques
et faire en sorte que ces sommet serve à
quelque chose dans les années qui
viennent
justement on a une question avec notre
partenaire orange et leur application
tivi tchèque est une question de thomas
pourquoi contraindre les pays émergents
à l'économie verte alors que les pays
développés se sont gavés et misent
maintenant par exemple sur les gaz de
schiste
les etats unis le canada développe
développe l'exploration voit que
l'internaute accède à quoi que
l'internaute mois les la terminologie
d'économie verte me laisse un peu
songeur je crois qu'il ya une économie
qui doit être fondée sur un autre modèle
de développement une économie moins
consommatrice d'énergies fossiles
notamment plus soucieuse la planète donc
je crois effectivement qu'un des
problèmes c'est la manière dont les pays
du nord se comportent aujourd'hui à
l'égard des pays du sud à vous parler
les pays bas il ya aussi la france est
ce que dans ce contexte de crise le
gouvernement actuel peut aller plus loin
dans les mesures environnementales
écouter au moment de l'organisation du
grenelle de l'environnement il y avait
toute une série de mesures qui avaient
été adoptées et notamment je me souviens
du discours de clôture de nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque qui avait chiffré en
fait donc de création possible d'emplois
verts il avait
dit qu'il était possible dans le cadre
d'une transition écologique te crées à
peu près de sept cent mille emplois
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la question de
la création d'emplois est une question
fondamentale mais la crise est passée
par là
oui mais la crise justement permet à un
moment donné réorienter de redéfinir des
priorités est de voir les secteurs où il
ya de la possibilité de création
d'emplois femmes ayant deux ministres
selon moi comme ça il en faudrait plus
des ministres vers moi je me réjouis que
cécile duflot et pascal canfin et
accéder à des responsabilités
importantes qui ne soit pas cantonné à
une espèce de petite chasse gardée
environnementale cécile duflot assume un
portefeuille crucial qui est celui de
l'égalité territoriale et 10 logements
et pascal canfin présent à rio
d'ailleurs à gérer les questions de
développement et de lutte notamment
contre la financiarisation de l'économie
dans sa très bien ça ira bien c'est la
bonne jauge pour l'ensemble du
quinquennat je pense que l'important
c'est leur capacité à avoir un budget un
périmètre ministériel reconnue établie
et puis on verra au fur et à mesure si
on a besoin d'élargir et les communistes
enfin le front de gauche qui refuse de a
priori d'entre eux gouvernement ce ça
fait vos affaires aussi ça vous n'en
mangez dans un tête à tête ce tête à
tête moi je vous dis que la gauche a
besoin de se rassembler que ce
rassemblement la passe également par une
poignée participation large au
gouvernement l'état major socialiste se
mobilise depuis depuis dimanche pour
trouver un point de chute pour ségolène
royal est apparemment la question ne se
pose pas pour eva joly il va l'alléger
la rue des écrans radar définitivement l
appât du tour disparu des écrans radars
elle est à rio et les priant de la
commission développement moi je pense
alors ça c'est vraiment un penchant
français notamment des journalistes
considérer quand on est élu au parlement
européen on a disparu au cimetière des
éléphants moi je trouve que l'europe est
une
chance pour la manche que le parlement
est dérivée des ambitions vous le savez
un mam le ministre de la justice et
l'expriment constitutionnel écoutez le
conseil constitutionnel sera renouvelée
au mois de février on verra d'ici là
très bien merci beaucoup surtout quand
on a des bons voyage donc de retour dans
un des pays donc dont vous êtes l'élu
merci en amérique latine et jusqu'aux
caraïbes merci bonsoir à tous
fermé en 1960 le tramway de strasbourg a
ressuscité en 1994
je voulais désengorger sauver le coeur
de la ville d asphyxier et en même temps
connecté toulouse au cac de la vie
puisque certains ne venait pas quels
changements at il introduit dans la vie
des strasbourgeois
son bilan est il vraiment positif
réponse dans le nouveau numéro de
attention grands travaux jeudi 18h30 sur
mac sénat en ce début d'année une
question et une seule taraude les
journalistes présents ce jour là est ce
que vous allez vous marier avec carla
bruni et quand c'est la seule grosse du
marché qui est capable de brosser aussi
bien les flancs que le taux de l'animal
est le président de cette race basques
des ports off winner c'est quand même
bon à bisel l'agriculture française ne
peut pas rester en marge de
l'agriculture mondiale ont clairement la
porte aux ogm
il en va de l'avenir de l'agriculture et
de l'agro business mais effectivement en
train d'opérer le grenelle aujourd'hui
j'ai été sénatrice en colombie j'ai
toujours pensé que c'est
institution porte la dp qu'elle
représente pour moi le sénat ne gagnera
la bataille de l'image que chi partout
dans cet hémicycle où nous organise
l'accueil qui accompagne l'arrivée de
ségolène royal avait quelque chose quand
même
c'est assez spectaculaire tous ceux qui
ont l'essentiel en commun et le courage
aujourd'hui de se rassembler bertrand je
t'ai entendu tout à l'heure il m'a dit
vous n'avez pas le droit vous êtes les
seuls où les socialistes à pouvoir nous
redonner cet espoir cette espérance
pendant si longtemps en amérique
les noirs ont été des citoyens de
seconde classe et maintenant on dirait
que les américains sont en train de me
surprendre
je
yes we can
bonjour cette semaine nous allons
prendre un peu de hauteur et chercher la
nature là on ne l'attend pas en plein
coeur de la ville sur nos toits en effet
de plus en plus de toiture sont
maintenant recouverte de véritables
jardins et ces lieux ne sont pas
réservées uniquement à quelques
privilégiés
la ville de paris notamment on cherche à
les rendre accessibles à tous alors
quels sont les avantages de ces jardins
suspendus sont il réalisable partout et
surtout comment les entretenir
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans ce
nouveau numéro des pieds sur terre
aujourd'hui en france seuls 1% des
toitures sont végétalisées
pourtant elle comporte de nombreux
avantages écologiques esthétique mais
aussi économiques
certains franchissent donc le passé le k
de mazac rohani un architecte paysagiste
qui vient de réaliser ce jardin terrasse
en plein coeur du xiiie arrondissement
de paris
en fait pas le mélange elle a été fait
on se retrouve avec la pouzzolane la
terre végétale les cailloux va falloir
qu'on répartisse à va falloir que tu
bouges les machins et tupras une petite
taille ouais je fais le tout de suite
parce que il faut faire ou ce soit un
bon jour alors vous êtes donc architecte
paysagiste est en train de réaliser un
toit-terrasse ici expliqué nous un peu
comment ça fonctionne est-ce que déjà on
peut imaginer ce type de jardin partout
théoriquement on peut en faire partout
c'est une technique qui peut être
appliqué sur des surfaces qu'on peut de
portance comme des surfaces campus de
portance ensuite à une question d'
angles d'inclinaison mais sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on a des techniques comme
les murs végétalisés
on peut même avoir une toiture verticale
donc effectivement pas en mettre
quasiment partout est ce qu'on peut
imaginer tout mettre dans ce type de
3tera c'est à dire des plantes des
fleurs des arbres j'imagine qu'il faut
un minimum de profondeur de terre alors
le strict minimum ses 5 cm et c'est
c'est pas les plus courants en général
c'est aux alentours d'une dizaine de
centimètres pour avoir une végétation un
petit peu de ce type là du cdh homme
classique ce qu'on voit un petit peu
partout autour ça pas besoin de beaucoup
de beaucoup de terre et ça n'a pas
besoin de beaucoup de nutriments et
quasiment aucun entretien
on peut envisager de mettre à peu près
n'importe quel type de végétation
ensuite qu'ils règlent à le type de
végétation ça va être la profondeur de
terre les arbres il faut quand même
compter 80 cm de terre ce qui n'est pas
le cas ici partout vous avez sans doute
dû voir on peut mettre des bacs et à ce
moment-là planter des végétaux un petit
peu plus conséquent un petit peu plus
grands qu'ils prennent plus de place
et sinon on peut quasiment mettre tous
types de végétaux sur une toiture
végétalisée
quels sont les avantages de ces toits
terrasses on a des économies d'énergie
qui sont réalisés
parce que c'est un isolant thermique
totalement naturel ça empêche les
déperditions de chaleur et sa conservent
la fraîcheur en été et ensuite s'il ya
tout un tas de davantage qui sont
relatifs à l'environnement
ça crée des niches pour les pour les
animaux c'est un puits de carbone ça
assainies l'air quelles sont les
contraintes que vous rencontrez sur ce
type de chantier alors il faut avoir une
portance quand même pour une toiture
classique il faut savoir que ça tourne
aux alentours d'une centaine de kg par
mètre carré
les contraintes fois minimum
d'accessibilité pour pouvoir assurer
l'entretien
et voilà c'est à peu près tout mais en
général on y va une ou deux fois par an
pour enlever les mauvaises herbes
s'assurer que la végétation a bien tenu
l'hiver surtout et remplacé éventuelles